hey what is up guys I'm Cathy HD here
and this is one of the most anticipated
phones of the year especially for me
someone who likes stock Android phones
this is the Nexus 6p and this is what
comes in the box it's a little different
from normal because it's a USB type-c
phone so you get a small USB a two USBC
cable about 8 inches long and then you
get a four foot USB C 2 USBC cable which
you use with the fast charging wall
adapter you see here straight up USB C
so if you weren't already convinced USB
type-c as the future
you should be now anyway there's some
other paperwork a free trial to Google
Play Music all access and a SIM card
removal tool and then the phone in all
its glory now this is just the unboxing
and first impressions but right off the
bat I can tell you I like the way this
phone feels in the hand but I am biased
I like big phones I cannot lie and I've
been using big phones for a while so it
doesn't seem huge to me but up next to
the massive Nexus 6 you can see it's
almost every bit as tall almost as wide
and it feels only more compact in the
hand because it's a lot thinner and has
flatter sides so props to Huawei on
making it feel a little better with that
and it's nice to finally get a better
look at the phone under my own lighting
to see the finer details like the ridged
power button and the USB type-c port at
the bottom even just the finish of the
darker color the graphite I'm glad this
was my top choice although pretty much
all the options look pretty good in
their own way so I popped the main SIM
card in and this guy and went through
the setup process exactly three days
before this video is being uploaded so
it's in action and has been as my daily
driver right now and I'm beyond pumped
to share my thoughts when I get to put
this thing fully through its paces
giving a fair shot of a couple more days
but one thing I do have set up is the
fingerprint sensor on the back with
Nexus imprint the setup was super easy
just like previous Android phones or
touch ID on an iPhone it reads your
finger a few times and then it does have
a feature where once you're done you can
unlock and wake up the phone just by
touching your finger on the back and
it's pretty quick too it's just got to
be careful not to do it in your pocket
since the fingerprint reader isn't a
sort of a natural resting place for the
finger where I guess it dimple usually
is on Motorola phones but I really like
the imprint feature so far and I'm going
to have to test things like the
front-facing speakers and the quad HD
display
and the Snapdragon 810 chip and its
performance and the biggest things for
me the camera and the battery life and
I've said this before I loved my first
impressions with this phone if you watch
that video you already know just keeping
it honest with you but I've said the
camera and the battery life have to live
up to the hype for me for this to be the
complete package there is no perfect
smartphone at all but so far the camera
is looking pretty good with limited
testing obviously despite not having
optical image stabilization and the
battery life is also promising seeing as
Android 6.0 has made some big
improvements in battery management when
the phone is asleep so either way this
is all going to be detailed in the full
review so make sure you subscribe to be
among the first to see that either way
that's been it for the Nexus 6p just a
quick unboxing and first look in case
you're wondering the Nexus 5x I got has
the exact same stuff in the box - that
short little USB a cable just FYI so go
ahead and follow on Twitter to start
seeing Nexus 6p photos from the camera
and battery life notes and all sorts of
other stuff as I go along that's been it
thank you guys for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next one peace
you